please note that this episode was
recorded in the weeks prior to George
Floyd's death it therefore doesn't cover
recent events directly but our
discussion of trauma PTSD that's post
traumatic stress disorder and promising
treatments has never been more relevant
thank you for listening at this altitude
I can run flat out for a half mile
before my hands start shaking annoyance
is a personal question
[Music]
I'm a cybernetic organism living tissue
over metal endoskeleton this podcast
episode is brought to you by helix sleep
sleep is super important to me in the
last few years I've come to conclude it
is the end-all-be-all that all good
things good mood good performance good
everything seem to stem from good sleep
so I've tried a lot to optimize it I've
tried pills and potions all sorts of
different mattresses you name it and for
the last few years I've been sleeping on
a helix midnight lux mattress I also
have one in the guest bedroom and
feedback from friends has always been
fantastic it's something that they
comment on helix sleep has a quiz takes
about two minutes to complete that
matches your body type and sleep
preferences to the perfect mattress for
you with helix there's a specific
mattress for each and every body that is
your body also your taste so let's say
you sleep on your side and like a super
soft bed no problem or if you're a back
sleeper who likes a mattress that's as
firm as a rock they've got a mattress
for you too helix was selected as the
number one best overall mattress pick of
2020 by GQ magazine wired Apartment
Therapy and many others just go to helix
sleep calm slash Tim take their two
minutes sleep quiz and they'll match you
to a customized mattress that will give
you the best sleep of your life they
have a ten year warranty and you get to
try it out for 100 nights risk-free
they'll even pick it up from you if you
don't love it and now my dear listeners
helix is offering up to $200 off of all
mattress orders and two free pillows at
helix sleep comm slash Tim these are not
cheap pillows either so getting two for
free is an upgraded deal so that's up to
$200 off and two free pillows at helix
sleep comm / Tim that's helix HDL is
slash Tim for up to $200 off so check it
out one more time helix h e li x sleep
comm slash Tim
this episode is brought to you by
LinkedIn jobs now more than ever
businesses are grappling with incredibly
challenging times a lot of things in
life and business are changing and we're
all adapting to new priorities while it
does take time to adjust
LinkedIn believes that it's also
possible to find and create
opportunities in times of turbulence and
times of change whether you're looking
to hire now for a critical role or
thinking about needs that you might have
in the future LinkedIn jobs can help
LinkedIn is an active community with
more than 675 million members worldwide
LinkedIn screens candidates for the hard
and soft skills you're looking for while
putting your job in front of candidates
looking for job opportunities that match
exactly what you have to offer with
LinkedIn you can hire the right person
quickly when you need them and if you
need to hire for health care or
essential services you can post your
jobs for free right now when it's time
to find and hire that right person
LinkedIn is here to help
just visit linkedin.com slash tim again
that's linkedin.com slash tim to post a
job now
terms and conditions apply hello boys
and girls this is tim ferriss welcome to
another episode of the Tim Ferriss show
this episode has been a long time in the
works I wanted to get it just right Rick
Doblin PhD I've wanted to have Rick on
this show for a long time indeed and we
wanted to get all of the pieces of the
puzzle together first which I think we
did Rick Doblin PhD is the founder and
executive director of the
multidisciplinary Association for
psychedelic studies maps this is an
organization that I've gotten to know
over the last handful of years and have
supported he received his doctorate in
public policy from Harvard's Kennedy
School of Government where he wrote his
dissertation on the regulation of the
medical uses of psychedelics and
marijuana and his master's thesis on a
survey of oncologists about smoked
marijuana versus the oral THC pill in
nausea control for cancer patients
Rick was also one of the early students
under the legendary dr. stanislav grof
Rick also more than perhaps anyone else
has a
thousand foot view of almost all of the
players all of the opportunities all of
the pending possible breakthroughs in
the world of psychedelics he knows just
about everyone and also has an
international scope of understanding so
he is to me at least endlessly
fascinating to speak with and kind of
the tip of the spear in many respects
the website is maps org and related is
maps org slash capstone we'll talk more
about that please listen all the way to
the end there is a big surprise that
involves ten million dollars and much
more so be sure to stick around to the
very very end and without further ado
please enjoy my conversation with Rick
Doblin Rick welcome to the show Sam it's
great to be doing this with you today
we've spent quite a bit of time together
we've traded a lot of emails we've
learned up a lot of minutes via cell
phone and I'm thrilled to finally be
having a public conversation with you
and I thought we could start with the
origin story of maps
how did maps come to be well let's start
with maps were started in 1986 and it
was actually the second nonprofit that I
started the first one I started in 1984
with two women
Elise Hagar and Debby Harlow and it was
Earth metabolic design lab but it had
been affiliated with Buckminster Fuller
and the friend of mine had started it
and wasn't using it and so that
nonprofit was started in order to gather
support from the psychedelic therapy
community in anticipation of the DEA
moving to criminalize MDMA which at the
time they only knew about ecstasy and so
from early 84 up until 86 we're working
with Earth metabolic design lab and our
main focus was once in the summer of 84
once DEA moved to criminalize MDMA
there's a 30-day public comment period
and I went to
and walked in to the DEA offices on date
28 or 29 and demanded a DEA
administrative law judge hearing to
argue that MDMA should stay available as
a therapeutic drug and we ended up
getting administrative law judge
hearings and we actually ended up
winning that hearing and what that means
is that the judge says a recommendation
to the head of the agency so it was the
DEA administrator and the judge said
that MDMA should be Schedule three
meaning that it should be able to be
used as medicine a prescription medicine
for psychotherapy for a whole range of
different things and the administrator
of the DEA rejected that recommendation
so it was very clear that there was no
way that we were going to be able to use
the law to keep the therapeutic use of
MDMA legal which had been used since the
middle 70s to the early 80s about half a
million doses had been used by
psychiatrists and psychotherapists and
some of those people that had
experienced it decided that more people
should have it that they could make a
bunch of money they turned it into
ecstasy and so once this effort that we
had attempted with multiple years
multiple people to try to protect it
through the law then I recognized that
the only way to really bring MDMA back
as a legal substance was through the FDA
was through science through medicine
through working with people that are
suffering and showing that there was
value there and so that's really when
maps was created in order to try to be a
non-profit Pharma to move MDMA and other
psychedelics and marijuana through the
FDA okay so we we timestamp
that several decades ago you along with
a number of other friends like roland
griffiths have been fighting the good
fight and pushing the ball forward with
great resistance at points for a very
long time
and first I want to thank you for that
but let me just mention some of what
we're seeing now and then I want to go
back in time to closer to the founding
of maps yeah okay so MDMA I want to
speak to some of the effects of MDMA
that we can talk about what exactly MDMA
is and maybe contrast it with other
things that can also be being interest
so I'm reading here from a recent
bulletin from maps so in maps completed
phase two trials with a hundred and
seven participants
this is mdma-assisted psychotherapy for
PTSD so a post-traumatic stress disorder
56% no longer qualified for PTSD after
treatment with mdma-assisted
psychotherapy measured two months
following treatment at the 12-month
follow-up 68% no longer had PTSD most
subjects received just two to three
sessions of mdma-assisted psychotherapy
so I want to underscore that part first
it's not three times a week indefinitely
this is two to three sessions of
mdma-assisted psychotherapy and then the
next piece I think is is worth letting
people take in all participants had
chronic treatment-resistant PTSD that
means it's failed other interventions
before or other interventions have
failed I should say and had suffered
from PTSD for an average of 17.8 years
so that that yeah seems to defy almost
any conventional psychiatric explanation
that one would have of mental illness
and possible treatments right so I want
to just mention that but let's go back
in time so that that's just a a preview
of things to come but let's go back in
time MDMA I guess it's
methylenedioxypyrovalerone sassafras
safrole oil that are you
as precursors to make MDMA but it does
not itself appear in nature and it was
actually invented in 1912 by merck
pharmaceutical company and they were not
looking to create MDMA they were looking
to evade a competitor's patent on a
synthetic route to get to a different
drug and so they found a new pathway and
they patented every drug along the way
MDMA happened to be one of those drugs
and as far as we know from the records
of Merck they did nothing with it for 15
years until their patent was about to
expire and they did some studies and
animals and found nothing interesting
this is 1927 the next we know of it and
this will help explain what it is was in
1953 where the US Army chemical warfare
service we're looking for mind-control
drugs and they tested a series of drugs
for toxicity and animals and MDMA it was
one of those drugs the other drugs went
from methamphetamine on one side to
mescaline on the other so MDMA is
basically half way more or less
chemically between methamphetamine and
masculine so of all the classic
psychedelics MDMA is the most liked
mescaline from peyote so it's got the
energizing properties of methamphetamine
but it doesn't make you jittery you can
sit quiet people have taken half doses
and it's facilitated meditation and it's
like the sort of psychedelic properties
of bringing to awareness inner material
that masculine has but it doesn't do it
in the same kind of ego dissolution way
the ego generally stays intact and so
that research was actually classified
and wasn't released until the early 70s
so people didn't really know about that
and in the Civic's teas there was a drug
called MDA which is
methylenedioxypyrovalerone side of
medical
contexts and when all of those drugs got
criminalized in 1970 with the Controlled
Substances Act and even before a chemist
named Sasha Shulgin had been looking his
at various psychedelics and trying to
understand structure-activity
relationships and he had had his first
psychedelic experience with mescaline
and felt that that was extraordinarily
profound so he was tinkering with the
mescaline molecule with with other drugs
he was aware of MDA and he sort of
independently resynthesized it and the
way Sasha and his wife Ann worked is
that they would take the drugs that they
created themselves first Sasha would do
it in very low doses he would work the
doses up if he thought it was something
important he would share it with Anne
and they would do it together and then
if they thought it was important they
had a group of 12 people that they would
share it with and this would be a team
that was very experienced testing out
all sorts of new psychedelics that Sasha
had invented and then once they got this
whole range of perspectives from this
group of 12 people if they still thought
it had value then the next step was a
fellow named Leo Zeff and Leo was the
leader of the underground psychedelic
psychotherapy movement Retief secret
chief and yes so we've published the
book the secret chief and then after a
few years when his family got
comfortable we published the secret
chief revealed so it's okay for us to
mention his name and so Leo was about to
retire he'd been mostly working with LSD
and other classic psychedelics and he
was going to retire and when he tried
MDMA he felt that it had such incredible
potential that he decided not to retire
and so from the middle 70s he started
training psychiatrists and
psychotherapists and others in the use
of this new drug and it was really there
that its therapeutic potential was both
I would say discovered expanded on and
it revitalized a lot of the the
psychedelic community because now once
the psychedelic research was
shut down near the end of the 60s early
70s a lot of the psychedelic researchers
went on to other things to study
meditation or mindfulness or other
different things and some small group
still continued to work underground but
they had tools that were basically
illegal and so now they had this tool
MDMA that was legal and it was kept
quiet for fear that if it was something
that entered the public consciousness
the DEA would criminalize it and that's
actually what eventually did happen but
but a lot of people don't realize is
that MDMA was a therapy drug before it
became a party drug under the name
ecstasy and it was really in Dallas at
the start club where MDMA really sort of
flourished as ecstasy and became quite
well known and that's what really
attracted the attention of the the DEA
and so then in the summer of 84 they
moved to criminalize it but what it does
it's remarkable in that it's very subtle
it's a subtle shift from normal
perception you can say that the classic
psychedelics are anything but subtle you
know you've taken them but this you do
know you've taken MDMA but it's it's
you're thinking is clarified your
feelings are a little bit clearer
there's a reduction of activity in the
amygdala there's reduction of fear
response there's a lot of oxytocin
release which is the hormone of love and
nursing mothers and so people feel more
self compassion self love self
acceptance the self-critical part of the
mind is kind of quieted and people
become more able to express their
feelings that our listeners it was used
quite a lot in couples therapy and so
it's got an enormous wide range of
applications and it can be used for
post-traumatic stress disorder which we
chose for strategic reasons and it's
also excellent for PTSD but it but it
has a whole wide range of other uses and
so I think it will become one of the MOU
widely used psychedelics once we make it
into a medicine so let's let's pause for
a second I want to highlight a few
things that you said number one it's
been said that two beings are mostly
responsible for creating psychedelics
God and Sasha Shulgin and and if if
people want to learn more about Sasha he
co-authored with his wife two books Peak
Hall I think it's a chemical love story
or something like that as a subtitle
which is the Neth Allah means I've known
and loved it's incredible encyclopedia
of drug / psychedelics and if you've
ever heard of mescaline I'm not sure if
they'd be referred to as derivatives or
analogues but to see b2c II the 2cx
class then you you're familiar with
Sasha Shogun's work and then there's a
tea call which is tryptamines I've known
and loved which is a similar compendium
different class of drug mescaline would
be an example of a finesse allah miyan
whereas something like DMT would be an
example of a tryptamine for those people
who know those acronyms but such
children fascinating character and
prolific I want to say certainly
hundreds maybe thousands of different
compounds that were they were created
yeah
yeah and also I learned a lot from him
about his political strategy of say
staying free in that one of the things
that Sasha did was he shared his
information with everybody could I pause
for one second just to say also he was a
a renowned chemist not just among
underground therapists but also he was a
known quantity to for-profit sort of
contracted chemists working with large
companies I just want to mention that as
well oh yeah he worked for Dow Chemical
and it invented it was like a
biodegradable insecticide or something
and he was rewarded by Dow and they said
you can have a lab and do whatever you
want you're so creative just will give
you a lab and do whatever you want
and he started focusing more and more on
psychedelics this was as the six seasons
going on and he eventually came to part
ways with Dow and went independent and
taught chemistry at UC Berkeley and yeah
he was very well renowned Campbell and
you were saying his strategy for
maintaining freedom so he said yeah yeah
so yes sure staying free he actually had
a DEA official that officiated at his
wedding with an children that's
incredible so he would he would develop
these friendships with people and it
would be by sharing information and he
had his connections through the whole
breadth of society so that there was you
know he would share it publicly with
chemists who would then learn what he
did and build on that or he would share
it with the DEA he just had this view
that if he ends up learning something
it's his obligation to share it with the
world and that that's the way to stay
safe that that he had personal trusting
relationships with people in the DEA
even though he was fundamentally against
the drug war and saw it as a major
abridgement of human rights but he could
meet people for who they were as
individuals not necessarily as
representatives or embodying all
the values of the organizations that
that they work it was just very
important
you've been very good at at maintaining
some degree of Swiss neutrality I would
say and I mean that as a compliment from
a diplomatic standpoint because even
within the psychedelic communities
you've got the kind of drum and feather
crowd who might hate the scientist crowd
and then the scientist crowd who doesn't
like the new shamanic fill-in-the-blank
crowd and then the ayahuasca people
don't like the LSD people like you there
there is a surprising amount of caddy
bitchiness within the sort of factions
of the psychedelic community that are in
some cases working together very well
but you've been extremely strategic use
that word before
and we'll talk we'll talk more about
strategy I want to just define a few
things real quickly
you said post-traumatic stress disorder
this is something that may be at some
point in the future I will discuss from
a personal perspective but I'm not going
to get into that this episode suffice to
say it's something I'm quite familiar
with and for those people who don't know
so PTSD I'm just going to read here PTSD
this is actually from a psychedelic
science funders collaborative document
that you have you have seen we won't
read the whole thing but and we'll
certainly talk more about PSF see later
probably so PTSD post-traumatic stress
disorder is a serious and prevalent
psychiatric condition that is the cause
of significant morbidity mortality
that's a pretty sterile boring way to
put it but it affects people you might
expect like military veterans and it
could go by a different name like
shell-shocked right people who have have
difficulty reintegrating and functioning
in civilian society but PTSD is also
extremely common in the civilian
population people who have been exposed
to war zones people who have been
physically or sexually abused there are
many different types of traumatic
experiences and it causes subjective
distress can lead to alcohol or drug
abuse and pair of societal family and
relationships certainly people with
severe symptoms may not be able to hold
job
may draw their blinds and stay indoors
in really bad cases and it also
increases the risk of other conditions
like depression and suicide and so on
which is higher in PTSD patients than
the general population so I wanted to
just give that as a basic but let's make
that concrete and I'm going to use a
more recent example and then we're going
to go back in time to I think in 1984
with you but could you tell us who John
Liu Becky is and why he came into your
sort of into your life for lack of a
better way to put it yeah so John is a
veteran from Iraq and he had been blown
up was not so physically hurt but he was
physically hurt some but he was more
psychologically damaged and when he came
back from the war he was so
decompensating that he ended up
attempting suicide on multiple occasions
including one time where he put a gun to
his head and pulled the trigger and
luckily the round didn't work he called
it a squib load and so he came very
close to death and out of desperation he
decided that he would volunteer for this
MDMA study and he was one of the very
successful cases I didn't know about him
for a while because as the sponsor of
research I'm not supposed to know who
the subjects are their privacy is
protected I only know when they reach
out to me or they are willing to reach
out to their therapist they and they say
that they want to either speak in public
about what happened to them about how
much benefit they got or or whatever so
it was a couple years after John's
treatment that was successful that we
got in touch and what I felt immediately
was that his story was so compelling and
he had been completely disabled with
PTSD
and after our treatment he was able to
go back to work and he was actually the
liaison to the veterans for Senator Rand
Paul for his 2016 presidential
nomination campaign for the Republican
nomination and so when I met John he was
doing much better but he also had
political connections and so I felt that
that's really what we need to broaden
the support for what we're doing to have
a veteran who's got connections with a
lot of Republicans who is willing to
speak about the benefits of MDMA and so
actually John has met with vice
president pans with Stephen Miller with
all sorts of Republicans that he was
able to speak with and have in a way the
first impressions that they get about
MDMA and the potential of MDMA to help
prevent suicides among veterans to help
veterans come back and lead more healthy
lives
they would hear about it from John so
now he's working as a consultant for
mash to try to broaden our political
support and I I highly recommend
everybody search online for a video you
can find it easily on YouTube from the
Economist which is actually a seven
minute I would call it profile of John
Liu Becky Lu bck why and it's if you
just search MDMA treatment PTSD The
Economist the video should pop up and
it's it's worth seeing because a few
stats to keep in mind there are 20 plus
veterans per day who commit suicide on
average in the United States that's one
and the recovery that we're talking
about at least as it was described in
Time magazine is not unusual given the
cohort right what I mean by that is on I
guess was May 1st of 2016
perhaps you could probably correct me
but the lancet psychiatry published a
paper about the study that that john was
involved with and roughly I want to say
two-thirds of the 26 veterans
firefighters and police officers treated
with mdma-assisted psychotherapy know
qualified for the diagnosis of PTSD one
month after their second MDMA session I
just want to again just underscore how
odd that is how unusual that that ratio
of number of doses to disappearance of
symptoms is in the world of psychiatry
and that that's where I want to go next
so part of what fascinates me about MDMA
is as you said how in some respects how
manageable it is compared to classic
psychedelics like LSD or yeah psilocybin
which would be associated with mushrooms
selasa tea mushrooms otherwise known as
magic mushrooms and in that respect it
is it is much easier to adapt to a
therapeutic context people can speak
intelligently and I find him dma deeply
fascinating for many reasons
one is that you see cross-species
offense so one word that is often used
to refer to or I should say a term that
is used to describe MDMA and some other
compounds is in pathogen right we're in
tact a Jim let's say in pathogen so a
compound that creates empathy and you
see this effect in for instance octopi
who exhibit pro-social behavior with
this this sort of down regulation of
fear response and and that's interesting
because their nervous system is
completely different than say many
mammals that have otherwise been studied
but in humans as you mentioned earlier
you have the turning down a volume on
the amygdala and what appears to please
correct me if I'm wrong but based on my
very novice understanding what appears
to happen in these therapeutic sessions
and people can see video of some of
these sessions in a film called trip of
compassion which I actually released I
mean I heared to help get it released in
the United States you just go to Tim dot
blog forward slash trip and you can find
it I don't make a penny from it but it's
it shows footage of
sessions with people who have
experienced PTSD and what strikes me is
that these people are able to revisit
traumatic experiences which would
otherwise be excruciating or impossible
to revisit without reach Ramat izing
themselves but with fear somewhat
removed or tone downed they can sort of
metabolize it and make sense of it as an
observer of their own experience and I
would just love to hear you comment on
that and also like how do you explain
how two sessions with something can have
enduring effects over months or years
after other interventions have failed
for an average of 17 years that just
doesn't make any sense to most people
who take psychiatric medications yeah or
do a lot of people at the VA who are
therapists who have had PTSD patients
for 30 years right that are still
struggling with PTSD so let me just say
that The Lancet article was published
May 1 2018 80 there we go and and and so
we paid for having it to be free to
download so if anybody goes to Lancet
calm slash psychiatry and just study
MDMA PTSD you can get to the article and
you can download it for free I think the
reasons why it's something that can make
a permanent change in people that
there's two factors the first factor is
the actual experience while they're
under the influence of the substance
while they're doing psychotherapy the
second factor is the integration work
and the work that that's what's really
necessary for making it permanent but so
you have like a breakthrough during the
session and then you work afterwards in
non drug psychotherapy to integrate it
but what we find is that you are
actually rewiring your brain so the same
neuroscientist Goal Dolan who did this
study with octopuses and showed that
octopuses who are a social unless it's
mating season which is almost which is
very rare but under the influence of
MDMA they'll be more pro-social so it's
a remarkable finding and so it goes
so deep in our evolutionary history that
we separated from octopuses they're like
550 million years ago but gull also did
studies in mice that were published in
Nature which is considered to be if not
the one of the top scientific journals
in the world and this study showed that
mice under the influence of MDMA release
a hormone oxytocin which is this hormone
as I mentioned of love and nursing
mothers but the oxytocin actually
stimulates new neural connections in
pro-social areas of the brain and
there's also a phenomena called fear
extinction and memory reconsolidation
and so the thought about memory is that
many people used to think about it as
you take a we've got sort of a hardwired
memory and you remember it and then you
go onto something else but actually when
you remember something you have to
reconsolidate the memory so that that's
how memories change over time and so
what we're able to do though with MDMA
is that there's a memory for the
incident episodic memory and there's an
emotional memory that's attached to that
incident memory but stored in different
parts of the brain and that they that
comes together and so when you're
feeling safe and you can bring up
painful memories and you are not
reacting in your normal way of fear and
re and a sense of being overwhelmed and
it's it's too much when you're able to
process the feelings and I'd say a lot
of the people in our studies have said I
don't know why they call this ecstasy
and you'll you know you'll see that by
looking at the trip of compassion video
to some of the sessions are very
difficult people are shaking they're
crying they're they're letting out stuff
that's been stored within for a very
long time but when they reconsolidate
the memory they are swapping out the
emotion that was attached when the
trauma happened a fear of Terror and
then they're swapping it out with a
sense of it's in the past
something that you have approached
peacefully you're feeling safe when
you're thinking about it you can
recognize it's not still happening so
the next time that you remember the
incident you remember the incident with
a different emotional tone and that that
can be encoded in new neural pathways in
your brain and what we find is that
under the influence of MDMA people's
memory for the trauma is increased and
you might think that that's a bad thing
now they can recall a lot more details
about the trauma and a whole sections we
had a firefighter that was in our study
and he and a bunch of his fellows were
in a fire that the roof caved in and
killed about eight or ten people he
survived and under the influence of MDMA
he remembered whole story segments of
what happened that he had he thought he
had the the memory stitched together and
the way it happened but under the
influence of MDMA he remembered more of
it and so when you have these memories
that are attached to fear when they're
unconscious and suppressed they're
influencing you the world is not a safe
place you've got to be suspicious of
this or that this could always happen
again so the fact that MDMA permits
memory to come to the surface where it
can then be processed with this fear
extinction and memory consolidation and
then it permits new neural pathways so
that you can actually change the way you
react in one session now this is also
true for a psilocybin psilocybin has
been shown to increase new neural
connections as well yep and other
psychedelics do so there's a kind of a
rewiring that helps explain how you can
have a fundamental change after just one
session but there still needs to be the
reinforcement of that and that's where
the psychotherapy and the integration
process comes in you could say but a lot
of people that take MDMA at raves and
and and take ecstasy at raves and
parties they can also have some pretty
powerful experiences but if they don't
do the integration work afterwards then
a lot of times the things will fade and
so that's why what we talked about our
treatment
is not really MDMA its psychotherapy
facilitated by MDMA right which is also
why you don't have every smoker who uses
psilocybin quitting nicotine but if you
have the structure and format like dr.
Matt Johnson at Hopkins did looking at
nicotine addiction and recruiting
subjects explicitly who want to quit you
have these just never before seeing
results with abstinence six months later
but it's it's the therapeutic vessel and
vehicle that is that is so important I
mentioned a few things related to that
number one Michael and Annie MIT Hoffer
are simply fantastic two exceptional
therapists who helped a lot with the
Maps protocol for therapy one of the
tools of the toolkit that we don't have
to get into right now but that I do find
useful and can be useful to people even
outside of the psychedelic context is
ifs I think that's internal family
systems yeah and if hearts work I think
is is surprisingly profound and powerful
when when used well let's talk about
another patient and that is from 1984 I
promised we would get to 1984 and just
just as a side note also because you
mentioned it but we didn't get into it
and I know we're bouncing all over the
place well actually first MDMA is and
this is true with other psychedelics but
it produces a hyper Nisha the opposite
of amnesia this this supercharged memory
that is quite incredible I mean you will
remember the texture of the couch the
exact pattern and fabric and color from
when you were three years old that could
come up something like that or words in
a language you studied for one semester
25 years ago it's it's it brings up a
lot of questions about the brain in the
mind and you mentioned that it can
produce these not just functional
changes in the brain but structural
beneficial changes yeah which is a
dashing on some level to think about and
then the the other acronym that I just
wanted to take a second to describe for
people because I think more people
listening to this will have heard of
MDMA than MDA I what are just in in very
brief terms what are the biggest
differences between MDA and MDMA I tend
to think of MDA is somewhere between
MDMA and LSD and having a much longer
duration of effect but how would you in
in brief contrast MDA versus MDMA pretty
much the way you just did I think it is
more in this kind of LSD MDMA
combination meaning that there is more
of ego dissolution it still got the body
warmth it still got the reduction of
fear so it's it's different than LSD or
psilocybin you can still converse during
most portions of it but the peak is more
nonverbal in different ways it's more
instinctual and it was used in therapy
as well and one interesting point was
that once MDMA became illegal you know
we could have thought that in the middle
70s early 80s when the use of MDMA was
so widespread in 30 settings that that
was because it was legal and the other
drugs were not and so once MDMA was
illegal then the question would be will
these underground therapists now that
all the tools are illegal will they go
back to MDA which was more popular
before MDMA and to most parts they have
not but it does have a lot of
therapeutic potential it is a pretty
incredible drug and it just is a little
bit more what we'd say psychedelic then
MDMA and I think that's why the
gentleness of MDMA the profoundness and
the way that it's such a subtle shift
makes it easier to integrate in the long
run not not as squirrely from yeah and
the MDA has more effect on the heart the
military when they were using at the CIA
mind control they actually killed
somebody with MDA by giving too high of
a dose and having heart problems so it's
got a little bit more of that
activation of the blood pressure blood
pressure got it just a quick thanks to
our sponsors and them are right back to
the show
first up LinkedIn jobs when it's time to
find and hire that right person LinkedIn
with an active community of more than
six hundred and seventy five million
members worldwide is here to help please
visit linkedin.com slash tim again
that's linkedin.com slash tim to post a
job today terms and conditions apply
second and last helix sleep sleep is the
end-all be-all for me of all of the
things you could optimize it is probably
the most important i've been sleeping on
a helix midnight luxe mattress for years
now luxe spelled l ux e and i have
another one in the guest bedroom the
feedback from friends has always been
fantastic helix is offering up to $200
off of all mattress orders and two free
pillows at helix sleep comm slash Tim
that's helix h e li x sleep comm slash
Tim for up to $200 off as promised I'm
obviously circling this slowly but 1984
and I believe this is the first the
first ever therapy session that you did
with a PTSD patient can you tell this
story please
yeah let me say that it was the first
ever therapy session that I ever did
with any important III I would sit with
people so so since 1972 when I was 18
and when I decided to go through
psychedelic therapy myself become a
psychedelic therapist tried to bring
back psychedelic research I would sit
for my friends and various other people
but these would be people looking for
personal growth and they were more or
less healthy people and of course all of
us who are more or less healthy have a
lot of problems - a neurotic you know
and every hit and everything else yeah
so I would deal with difficult cases but
the first time I ever dealt with patient
was in 1984 and so as part of my
training to become a therapist I had
studied with Stan Grof and Kristina at
Esalen the summer of September 82 is
when I first studied at Esalen with them
for a month-long workshop that's where I
learned about MDMA and then I went back
in 84 for a month-long workshop that
they had called the spiritual emergence
Network and the basis of that was that
there's a lot of people that are
struggling with what their purpose in
life is what's their meaning what are
they really care about how do they
approach death and and various issues
and that sometimes people have these
breakdowns and they can be catalyzed by
psychedelics they could be just a normal
breakdown and that all too often these
are breakdowns that could lead to
breakthroughs that these are
dysfunctional patterns and that they
they need something more healthy but
they break down and often that gets
pathologized and they get medicated and
hospitalized and tranquilized and and so
the theory of this spiritual emergence
network is that if we don't try to
suppress the symptoms but help people
work through their issues that they will
end up potentially finding a new balance
and be more healthy so I had gone
through a month-long training on how to
work with people
in these spiritual emergencies and I had
just come back home to Sarasota to
Florida to new college where I was a
student and I was only home for four or
five days and then a friend of mine
called me up and he said that he and his
girlfriend had done
MDMA together and under the influence of
MDMA she had remembered being raped and
almost killed and that this was a
terrifying memory for her she had
previously been in and out of mental
institutions as a result of this and
other traumas that she experienced and
she was so bothered that she might hurt
herself this painful memories had come
to the surface that she checked herself
into a mental institution and she stayed
there for about six days and they gave
her the same old drugs that she had
gotten before and discharged her and she
felt hopeless that these drugs had not
helped her before there was nothing that
she knew of and she was even more
deciding to try to kill herself and so
my friend called me and he said can you
help her and I had sold them the MDMA so
I felt that in some ways I was
responsible but I also felt like I have
just got this training in this spiritual
emergence work but I'm not qualified to
work with somebody that's out that
life's at the the razor's edge of death
and life that's so much worried about
committing suicide and so I felt that
this was one of the most important
turning points in my entire life and and
I felt like if I were to say no to her
she didn't really have any other options
she tried the best that Western medicine
could give her she'd been hospitalized
she'd been medicated none of that worked
and so I agreed to at least to talk to
her and so during our conversation I
asked her that if she would just promise
not to commit suicide when we were
working together I would take a chance I
would gather some women friends and we
would create a support system for her
and we would try to work with her
because what I knew about MDMA and I
think this is important for people to
realize is that it brings things to the
surface but if you're not prepared for
that you can end up worse off a lot and
that's where the therapy come
and it's not just giving the pill it's
the context it's how you react to this
internal material as it's coming up and
so Marcelo was the woman and she agreed
to not commit suicide while we were
working together and that gave me the
courage to work with her and so she came
down to Sarasota and and moved into my
house for about a month and we did it
first off we did an MDMA experience and
it was so hard it was so painful it was
like a tour of all the traumas that she
had in her life I think that's also a
clue for people is that most of us when
we experience trauma will be able to be
resilient and can get over it and it's
not always the case but those people
that end up with PTSD are often those
that have had a series of traumas
sometimes going back to childhood
um and so this was the case for Marcela
so the first session was MDMA and it was
a series of these traumas that she'd
experienced throughout her life and I
felt like we made a lot of progress but
it didn't feel to either of us like the
problem had been solved that she had
found a new way to move forward and so
the next thing I thought was let's try
LSD and so the next session began with
LSD this was about 10 days after the
first session so we we'd had first
session we had some integration time and
now we did an LSD session and during the
what I knew also about LSD is that it
was the first drug used in the treatment
of PTSD and it was the first psychedelic
drug and used in the treatment of PTSD
and it was used by a doctor Bastien's
who was a dutch psychiatrist and after
world war ii he started using LSD for
what he called concentration camp
syndrome and he worked with a lot of
Holocaust survivors but he also worked
with a lot of Dutch resistance fighters
who were in the camps and they later
after the war became part of the Dutch
government they protected him and
Bastian's was the last person in the
world that still had legal permission to
give LSD to people up until the late 70s
early the 80s so I knew that LSD had
been
for treatment of PTSD but that it had
been quite difficult and so under the
influence of LSD Marcella got
increasingly fearful that MDMA can
reduce the activity in the amygdala LSD
doesn't do that so the fear came and she
had these images of being on a foreign
planet under a double Sun and baking to
death and it was just too terrifying she
couldn't make any progress at all and
was stuck and so I thought well maybe if
we administer half a dose of MDMA that
would decrease the fear enough so that
she could continue to process what was
happening what was coming up to her and
her memories and so that was the
breakthrough was this half a dose of
MDMA and after that I half a dose you're
talking about like 75 milligrams
something like that yeah yeah 60 70
milligrams yeah that it just cut the
fear to the point where she could now
finally processing and so this symbolic
thing that she had about being in a
foreign planet with the double suns and
baking to death the the symbolism was
such that it was related to something in
her life so under the influence of MDMA
it condensed to being on earth with a
single Sun after she had been raped and
beaten and was thrown outside under the
Sun and left alone so it turned into
something in her life and then what she
started sharing was that this had been a
date rape situation and that this person
had told her that if she ever told
anybody about what actually happened or
mentioned his name that he would kill
her and so this had been about ten years
before that we she and I met but this
kind of feared that if you ever tell
anybody about he'd kill her that was
like a poison pill in her brain that she
was a prisoner of this and so being able
to tell the story broke the spell and
then I think what the next step was is
that when she explained that it was date
rape I said well what what did you like
about this guy
she immediately threw up it was this
just this instantaneous reaction of
throwing up and then she started
explaining that he had liked animals and
that what she had one of the reasons why
she was thinking of committing suicide
was that she could never trust herself
to find love to find companionship
because her previous instincts with this
guy had been so wrong and so going back
and being able to look at where she made
this mistake that that just because
somebody likes animals doesn't mean you
can trust them she started to regain her
ability to trust herself about how to
move forward in assessing threats
assessing how people are gonna act to
her and she was able to let out all of
the fears about what had happened to her
and so that was the transition for her
and we did not need to do a third
session that was the one that really
changed things for her and so that was
1984 and so over time as I was watching
how she was doing we kept in touch she
kept getting better and better and
better and I think that's another really
important thing to say is that she had
had these overwhelming feelings of fear
with these memories but under the
influence of MDMA the first session and
the LSD MDMA combination the second
session she was able to learn that if
you can bring these feelings to the
surface and express them that they don't
need to overwhelm you that you can
process things that you don't have to
launch into these fear-based reactions
and so what what you started out team by
saying early on is that people do better
at the 12-month follow-up and at the
two-month follow-up that even without
more MDMA and without more therapy that
they've learned a process about how they
handle their medications that they're
there their problems I mean in their
emotions and so that's the same thing
that happened for Marcela and so
throughout the 80s and into the 90s when
the whole concern about the rave
movement was growing and the NIDA funded
research the Nash
drug abuse funded researchers claiming
that MDMA was neurotoxic and would
produce long-term functional
consequences after a single dose I kept
watching Marcela and I kept seeing her
get better and better and better and she
later then decided that she wanted to
become a therapist she was an artist she
decided that she wanted to become a
therapist to help others and she went
back to school to become a therapist and
now she is one of our lead therapists
and she and her husband Bruce are one of
the lead trainers of other therapists
and that was an experience that really
motivated me to think about MDMA for
PTSD as being an ideal combination if we
zoom out from that that story of one
person I can also say that I personally
know at least a dozen people who have
had their emotional lives and
relationships with their loved ones
resurrected because of MDMA and these
these different compounds to the extent
that just as one example a friend of
mine had his wife say you're once again
the person I married right he had been
so withdrawn and shutdown out and
compartmentalized and self isolated that
he'd he ceased to resemble the person
she married and not to say this happens
all the time but it happens more often
than one might think within a very short
period of time like you said after two
or three sessions with competent
guidance ended up with with that type of
outcome and I'd like to hear what you
think of of this way of describing the
the session because I the importance of
the therapy is paramount and the way I
heard it put to me by someone who who
shall remain nameless but very hyper
credible people would recognize the
scientist but said what psychedelics do
is they create a window of plasticity
and then it's up to
the person and their environment and
their support to then mold to that
plasticity right so you create this
window of plasticity where you can grow
new you can experience a neurogenesis
right the generation of new connections
within the brain and so on and so forth
but to what end right for what is it
molded and you can hone your direction
with the help of therapists who then
provide you also with the toolkit that
continues to be useful after that
molding integration experience right at
least that that's been my impression so
it's it's not a foregone conclusion that
you take a pill and all your problems
are solved but with the right shaping
and guidance the outcomes can be really
just just incredible and when I think
about Marcella or think about you I
think about people like Roland who have
been involved for so long and for so
long with so little extrinsic reward if
that makes sense right I mean you think
you think about it scientifically for
decades it was considered just the
career suicide
at best okay and then and then it was a
dead end it's like all right it's not
career suicide but you're going nowhere
and then it was minimally interesting
and now you know the New York Times Wall
Street Journal these major media outlets
major universities are taking notice
funding is being raised but during those
hard times I'd love to hear what drove
you and I know there's one example that
you haven't spoken about in as public a
forum as this but that it's perhaps more
recent but I think it kind of speaks to
this which is the the suicide letter
that that perhaps you can ascribe for
people
yeah let me say first off that just to
further illustrate this story about it's
not just the drug and then we'll get to
that which is that one week about twenty
years ago Maps got contacted by two
women with almost identical stories they
had taken MDMA at raves and had
remembered being raped and prior sexual
assault but one of them told the story
that she was with friends who just
wanted to party and that she knew that
they didn't want to hear about this
heavier thing that was coming to the
surface and shows she stuffed her
feelings down and she had contacted us
months later feeling way worse and the
other woman who contacted us just days
away said that she was at a rave took
him do you made the same thing happen
but she was with a girlfriend and they
went off into the corner and talked
about what happened to her and they were
able to process it and then she was able
to go back to the party and now she felt
better after months later so it's not
the substance itself it's how you
respond to the material now what drove
me to do this in the first place was a
certain kind of desperation I would say
about about the world so when I was a
very young boy born in 53 from Jewish
family I was raised with stories of the
Holocaust I had distant relatives killed
a lot of Israeli relatives and just the
thought that there could be this
dehumanization and genocide and just
irrational thinking was terrifying to me
and and that led me more and more to
think about you know psychological
factors and so I just felt that there
was this imbalance that we as a species
have and that I as an individual have
where we are over developed in our minds
and underdeveloped in our emotions and
spirituality and so this was now about
15 years ago and I had been contacted by
this fellow who was quite troubled and
he wanted to be referred to an
underground psychedelic therapist and I
wasn't ready to do that and so he
happened to live not far from where my
therapist
down in Florida and so I referred him to
my therapist and he worked with my
therapist for a couple months at this
point I was in Boston I didn't live down
there but he went to my therapist for a
couple months and then he called me up
and he said it's just not doing what I
need to do I would like you to go ahead
and refer me to an underground therapist
and so we talked about it some more and
he indicated that he had had a tendency
towards epileptic seizures and it's
conceivable it's rare but it's possible
that psychedelics can catalyze a seizure
and I felt like the kind of underground
settings are just not appropriate for
somebody that could have a medical
crisis and so I said to him that I just
could not in good conscience refer him
to an underground therapist and and he
said all right he felt kind of sad and
and seemed to accept it and and and that
was the end of our conversation and I
didn't hear anything for about three
more months and then I got a call from
the police in his hometown and they said
do you know this guy and I was like at
first a little bit frightened I wasn't
sure what they were talking about and I
said yeah I do know him and and he did
contact me and I referred him to my
therapist and then he wanted further
therapy I wasn't able to help him with
that and they said well he's committed
suicide and he's left you a suicide note
and we wonder would you like to see it
and I was like taken aback but I said
yeah if he's written a note for me I
should I should want I should read it
no matter and I thought it was going to
be
you could have helped me but you didn't
I'm really mad at you why didn't you do
this and when I got the note the first
thing I noticed was that he hadn't
committed suicide a few days before then
he'd committed suicide the very next
morning after our phone conversation
after I told him I couldn't refer him to
an underground therapist and that
somehow had taken three months for the
police to get around to calling me so
that was shocking once I just saw the
date on his letter that that it was
connected to me giving him no more hope
that he decided that he would kill
himself and the note was the opposite of
what I thought it would be it wasn't
condemning me it wasn't angry it was
this kind of sad sentimental but
gracious note and he said I don't blame
you for not referring me to help I blame
the system I blame the drug war III I
feel that I might have been one more
person who would still be alive if this
therapy was legal and you can tell
people about this note if you want to do
so and that I just hope that my
experience will motivate others to try
to seek treatment and and motivate you
to keep trying because there's a lot
more people that need help like this it
was a beautiful note it was just so
tender in a way and then just to think
that he wrote that and then right then
after that killed himself and so that's
always been in the back of my mind that
that there are people out there people
that we know that need help you talked
about 20 veterans committing suicide
today there's roughly 50,000 people that
commit suicide every year in America and
we need to help them that and there's
way more whose lives are so warped by
PTSD or depression or anxiety or fear
that they need our how much time and we
are in a very exciting period right now
in terms of the place of momentum for
what you've been working on for somebody
decades and I'd like to bridge to that
because the the suicide letter you
mentioned speaks to the desperation it
also speaks to what types of therapies
could be available to people even if
they have certain medical complications
like epilepsy with proper supervision if
compounds were yeah reclassified meaning
they were taken from Schedule one the
most restrictive drug class no known
medical application high potential for
abuse or there may be other criteria but
things were thrown into there somewhat
willy-nilly during the Nixon
administration and it's it's
extraordinarily challenging to get them
out but I want to just speak to what's
happening right now and also perhaps saw
an anecdote first and that anecdote is
I've come to know we're recording this
during the kovat nineteen crisis it's
far from over this is going to be I
think a very long difficult period for
millions of people and I've become
friends with ICU Doc's
so senior attending physicians in New
York City and elsewhere and one of them
who's completely psychedelically naive
he's never used any of these compounds
reached out to me because he does not
know how to process what he is seen and
what he's had to do he's seen so much
death he's had to make decisions about
who gets ventilators and who don't he's
had to talk to say there's someone who
is older with a lot of a lot of
comorbidities who's probably not gonna
make it even if they intubate them and
talk to the family about why they're not
going to get a ventilator I mean things
like that and he doesn't know what to do
right and he said I say this just
because I think this is trauma and the
difficulty in resolving trauma and the
in efficacy of treatments for say PTSD
is so profound and it's also very timely
right I feel like right now talking to
these first responders talking to many
other people who have been affected
who have loved ones who have died who
are simply suffering from acute anxiety
and this is bringing a lot to the
surface that I'm kind of watching the
tide go out and that there's a tsunami
on the way of very high volumes of PTSD
and I also have personal experience that
I may discuss another time so for all of
these reasons right looking at the data
first of all being driven by that and
seeing results that represent an order
of magnitude jump from anything that is
close to being in second place seeing
video of the transformations that can
take place and I recommend everybody
watch trip of compassion if you can it's
it's very intense but the payoff is
worth it you meaning maps and PSF see so
the psychedelic science funders
collaborative have launched a 30 million
dollar capstone fund so this is a
campaign to get mdma-assisted
psychotherapy across the finish line and
make MDMA a medicine and after decades
and decades of working on this you have
a number of excellent people involved
with maps on the on the executive team
you have advisors now who have a lot of
experience in pharma biotech drug
development and I'm at a point I've been
waiting for this point you might not
know this but I've contributed to maps
over the years in smaller ways and I've
been waiting for this precise window so
you're raising thirty million to get it
to the finish line you've already raised
internally from people you know around
ten million yes MLE and over the last
week or so and it's been an incredible
week a lot of things have come together
beautifully I've worked with Joe Greene
who's president of PSF see that's the
psychedelic science funders
collaborative to get together a ten
million dollar matching grant originally
as you and I know we were going to
record this podcast and we didn't have
any matching grant then I thought let's
put together five I'll be part of that
five and then we ended up at ten and the
intention was to announce it as we're
doing on the podcast
I'll explain what that means and more
accurately it's a challenge grant so
you've got me I'm putting in a million
you've got Peter Rahal who's founder of
our X bar James Bailey founder of Bale
Capital Blake Mycoskie founder of Tom's
all seven-figure commitments then you
have Stephen Alexandre Cohen of the
Stephen and Alexandre Cohen foundation
coming in in a big way with five million
and you have other people who are also
committing capital and what makes this
so exciting
is that you've raised ten of the thirty
now we're committing to the middle ten
which is the hardest to raise right that
middle ten is often the most difficult
to raise in a challenge grant which
means that if other people are able to
donate ten million if Maps is able to
raise an additional ten million it
activates our ten million and boom we're
at the finish line which is hard to
believe it's quite amazing that all this
came together but well I'm so glad the
microphones didn't work the first time
and gave you something to do in this
period of delay yeah everything if
everything is happening for you and not
to you what does it look like and this
has been one of the stranger more
surreal and exciting things that has
ever happened from a tech delay and this
is extremely close to me and represents
such an opportunity and just to clarify
again ten million is raised of the 30 I
and the group I mentioned are committing
to a 10 million dollar challenge grant
which means if another 10 is raised to
activate that boom we're at this is so
close and to me represents such an
opportunity and I was speaking with a
doctor and a scientist who's who's been
advising you guys and he said you know
there are some risks but the asymmetric
risk reward is is just incredible
for this meaning you know once done
meaning if if you have MDMA reclassified
you know the ice is broken for a dozen
other things for the entire field for
the entire industry right so if you're
looking for a spearhead opportunity that
is time-bound right I mean this there is
time since
to this because you're executing Phase
three trials this is an immediate
opportunity that if you really want to
sort of bend the arc of history and if
you're interested in any of these other
compounds like psilocybin as I am I've
committed a lot of resources and time to
supporting research at places like Johns
Hopkins and Imperial College London you
have to be interested in the outcome of
this phase three trial with MDMA it is
it's it's going to be the precedent
Center so I'm I I was not planning on
making another large commitment like
this but is the moment as you're right
it is the moment and of course huge
thanks to Joe I don't want to skip over
that and we're looking for people who
can really help donate on any level you
can go to maps org to donate at any
level $1 $10 a month $20 a month but
we're especially looking for people who
can make larger donations and buy larger
donations I would say six figure or
seven figure commitments over a two year
period so my million dollar commitment
will be is planned for 500,000 in late
2020 so let's say around October and
then the remaining 500,000 in the end of
2021 let's just say October again so you
get to split it across multiple years
it's tax-deductible and so if you might
be able to contribute a hundred thousand
dollars or more over multiple years then
you have two ways that you can learn
more one is going to maps org forward
slash capstone that's number one map
style work forward slash capstone the
second and you can do both of course is
emailing capstone at maps org to set up
a meeting was Rick or a member of his
development team to learn more about the
groundbreaking work that they're doing
and contribute say $1 $10 $100 you can
go to maps org and set up some type of
ideally recurring donation that can that
can also add you to the chorus in
support of this to unlock the healing
power of
which has already really been
demonstrated and needs to be further
demonstrated through these phase three
trials and I'll just say one more thing
so they're they're a couple of benefits
actually so it's not going to be one
more thing will be a few more things the
there there are there are benefits to
doing this if you contribute in a big
way so let's just say if you're if
you're able to contribute a million or
more then you can participate in the
community known as PS FC of which Joe
green is is the president gram boy it
also does great work so the psychedelic
science funders collaborative PS FC
includes all sorts of members Matt
Mullenweg of automatic Genevieve and
Steve Jurvetson incredible entrepreneurs
and investors austin Hurst's jeff walker
george Sarlo and there are all sorts of
different sort of community threads PS
FC helps with due diligence and bringing
in advisory capacity specialists and so
on to assess different opportunities in
the psychedelic space there have been
group zoom chats with people like
Michael Pollan I believe Jared Diamond
if I'm not mistaken yes and and others
say there there are there are a lot of
fun things that are done with this
smaller group and I'll link to more on P
SFC but suffice to say this is a this is
an incredible opportunity this
represents I mean it represents a lot of
money to me that's not a small amount
one of my large contributions to
anything ever
and the reason that I'm doing this
because I've raising money is a hard
business Rick I mean you you've done it
for such a long time fundraising is is
tough and what I've noticed is that some
people seem to think they can take their
marbles with them and and you can't take
your marbles with you meaning the money
you have accumulated so I think it's
really worthwhile to ask if you do have
some flexibility and finances or some
some savings that could be applied to
something you care about you know if you
know someone affected
I trauma if you know someone whose lives
have been devastated by addiction which
was used to numb or avoid feelings that
are the result of trauma and you're
looking for a very high leverage
asymmetric payoff possibility this is an
excellent place to put money and I do
think that a dollar now is worth ten
dollars five years from now this is a
time dependent opportunity is the way
that I'm looking at it and you know if
not now if not with this if you've if
you find it of interest or if these
compounds have had a huge impact in your
life where are you gonna put the money
right like where else and you should
have a good answer to that before it's
an immediate no to this that's my
perspective right if you're just holding
all to it in case I just don't view that
as a satisfactory answer and maybe I'm
just I'm just
maybe I'm just all fired up but I mean
I've committed something like 5% of my
total net worth over my entire life
right everything I've done to
psychedelic science including this
capstone fund with maps it's it's it's
had such a tremendous impact in my life
it's completely changed my life for the
better I don't know if I would be here
without some of these compounds quite
frankly and I know I'm not alone in
feeling that way so
to put the numbers in context I also
want to say that over the history of
maps over 34 years we've raised over 80
million dollars and so now we're talking
about another 30 million and that will
get us approval if the research goes
well as we think it will in the United
States through the FDA in Israel through
the Israeli Ministry of Health and also
in Canada through Health Canada because
we have 15 phase 3 sites - in Israel -
in Canada and 11 in the United States so
the other number to put in context here
is the number that it normally takes
Pharma to develop drugs into medicines
and it's hundreds and hundreds of
millions of dollars the pharma industry
will tell you that it's well over a
billion dollars in fact the latest
number is roughly two billion dollars to
make a drug into a medicine but what
they do is they amortize all their
failures into the few successes around
half of the money almost is opportunity
cost on their money then they have to do
a long period of safety studies which
fortunately for us because MDMA is such
an ecstasy such a demonized drug there's
been hundreds in thought there's if you
go to MEDLINE there's over 5,000 papers
on MDMA or ecstasy at a cost of
somewhere in the neighborhood of 450
million dollars to produce all this data
that we've been able to review and
assess and then submit to FDA so that
we're gonna end up spending for Phase
three is somewhere in the neighborhood
of 65 million or so with 35 million
already raised and then another 30
million coming from capstone and it's
the the median is around never the low
end is somewhere like 350 million for
pharma to make a drug into a medicine so
the things that contribute to us being
able to do it so efficiently are first
off we have a bunch of highly
mission-driven people we have 80 people
now working for maps we don't work at
pharma salaries we a lot of them are
what we call refugees from pharma from
Novartis
and other pharma companies that are
really passionate about psychedelics
so we're mission driven
we're not returning money to investors
it's all about donations and then once
MDMA becomes a medicine it will be sold
in our Maps public benefit corporation
where we maximize public benefit over
profit and whatever profits there are
get reinvested in the mission of maps
for further research so it's extremely
efficient the other thing to say is that
there's only two drugs that have been
designated breakthrough therapies for
PTSD by the FDA one of them is MDMA or
mdma-assisted psychotherapy the other
was a drug called tanmaya by a tonics
pharmaceutical companies it was a
repurposed old drug from over 30 years
ago that was a sleeping pill and the
thought was that maybe they could make
it to help people sleep through the
night who have PTSD and not have
nightmares and get better rest and and
so we did our interim analysis in March
Mayas interim analysis was done in
February and they were they failed they
were told that the study was not going
to get significant results it failed for
futility and they had already spent well
over a hundred million dollars on this
study and that's all lost and we've got
lots of stories like John Liu Becky but
still to do it in the context of a
clinical study a phase three study a
very an invariable you know treatment
you know you can't customize it to the
person it was a little bit anxiety
provoking but when I opened the email
from the date of monitoring committee I
was just elated to learn that we didn't
need to add anybody that we have at
least a 90% or greater probability of
obtaining statistical significance when
the other people are finished the study
and that we have at least a medium
effect size which is good but our Phase
two data pooled was a large effect size
so we are on track we have D risk that
we have demonstrated in this in our
analysis that we have a very good chance
of succeeding and so I think that when
we
imagine you know investments in
charitable purposes you do have to take
the chance of is it going to work or not
but we cannot say that it's going to
work 100% but we believe that it will
work and one important thing also is
scaling and you hear this all the time
in in tech and you talked to earlier
about Michael and Annie Minho for being
you know these phenomenal therapists and
they're they are phenomenal therapists
they were our they treated more people
in Phase two than anybody else and so
what we decided to do for Phase three
was to take Michael and Annie out of
phase three and have them instead train
new therapists to conduct the phase
three studies and so Marcella and Bruce
are they're still working on Phase three
but they're also spending much of their
time training other therapists and so
what we've demonstrated in Phase three
was with about 70 new therapists many of
whom had never done MDMA before but they
had experience in trauma and they were
able to get phenomenal results that
we're on track so it's new therapists
who are able to get these results and so
that's why I really think that it's
going to be scalable should we obtain
FDA approval for prescription use and
this master grant that you're doing is
just phenomenal to really help us do
this we also have what's called an
agreement letter from the FDA special
protocol assessment process we went into
after we got permission from FDA to go
to Phase three we engage with them in an
eight month process where we reviewed
every aspect of the Phase three design
the statistical analysis plan and all
the other studies that they're going to
want to see and we managed to get what's
called an agreement letter and so that
agreement letter means that they are
legally bound to approve the drug if we
get statistically significant evidence
of efficacy and if there's no new safety
problems they can't question the
methodology or anything like that so I
think the the ninety percent is the you
know the best farm
will do for the regulatory the other
thing we should be concerned about is
you know backlash against psychedelics
you know how likely is that but one of
the most important things of our
fundraising so far has been that we have
obtained funding from people across the
political spectrum I think this is a
really important point because people
might assume that everyone donating to
this is sort of tie-dye wearing hippies
with a few extra coins in the pocket but
that's not true at all you have people
on say the right you've got Rebecca
Mercer you've got all sorts of folks
Elizabeth cook then on the let's just
say the left for sake of simplicity
you've got certain of the Rockefellers
who have donated millions you've got
people like George Soros so there's an
entire spectrum of donors who are
contributing to this cause and certainly
that minimizes the likelihood of
political backlash but it speaks even
more so to the fact that you have such
sympathetic populations who are trying
to help including veterans the disabled
american veterans just put out may 1
their bimonthly magazine and the cover
article is about MDMA for PTSD so I
think we're in we're in as best shape as
we could possibly be at the moment which
is why I've come off the bench and I'm
back on the field and I just want to I
just want to kind of simplify and
clarify a bunch of what was just
mentioned so first is very few
guarantees in life but I have decided to
re-engage and kind of push in all my
chips on this right now because I it is
being highly de-risked high probability
of success with very asymmetric payoff I
mean it opens the door paves the way
breaks the ice whatever metaphor you
want to use for potentially you know a
dozen compounds including psilocybin
this is a very very important what I
would consider say Vanguard moment and
initiative for psychedelics overall and
MDMA is the representative that is
furthest ahead so I'm putting in a
million of my own money which is a lot
of money for me we also have as I
mentioned before Peter Rahall and James
Bailey Blake Mycoskie and then of course
the Steven and Alexandra Cohen
foundation huge thanks to all of them
and others who are contributing money
for this ten million dollar challenge
grant and if you have the possibility if
you're open to considering donating six
figures meaning $100,000 or more over
multiple years then please check out
maps org forward slash capstone and you
can also email capstone at maps diamonds
I feel like I've done my homework on
this I mean I've been very immersed in
this world and the science for a five or
six years now and have given maps
smaller amounts of capital to see how
well that's used in the past I've done
that with other outfits in different
universities and this is the right time
to contribute so if you need more
convincing then I would suggest watch
the Jonathan libecki video created by
The Economist looking at MDMA is
treatment for PTSD also consider
watching trip of compassion you can find
that at tim dot blog forward slash trip
which i suggest everybody watch anyway
just because it shows how badly someone
can feel they are damaged and flawed and
irreparable and how they can regain
their footing in life and really feel
resurrected i mean it's it's incredible
to watch and you get to see it in visual
storytelling with real session footage
but i hope you guys will will join in
like if you've been sitting on the
sidelines wondering how can i support
how can i get involved and a lot of
people hundreds of people have asked me
this is a good place to place some chips
i'm putting in a lot of chips personally
so i'm not just talking the talk i'm
putting a lot of skin in the game and
yeah now that yeah there's another
background factor so we have tried the
traditional sources of funding and that
has not worked so for example there is
over a million veterans that are
receiving disability payments from the
Veterans Administration for PTSD and it
costs the Veterans Administration
somewhere in the neighborhood of 15 to
20 billion dollars a year on these
disability payments and they pay
multiple billions of dollars every year
on SSRIs and other things to treat
people with PTSD and yet we've not been
able to get a penny from the VA in fact
we are paying researchers affiliated
with the VA to blend MDMA with their non
drug psychotherapies as a way to try to
educate the VA so maybe one day they
will get involved but I don't think
they're gonna help us get it approved
the other thing is the National instant
mental health so last week there was an
article in The Washington Post about how
kovat is gonna produce as you said a
tsunami of mental health problems and
one of the people that was quoted was
the woman in charge of PTSD research at
the National Institute of Mental Health
and so we've been trying for about 15
years to get any kind of support from
the National Institute of Mental Health
and so I just sent her an email the
other day
and I said is there a way for NIH to
help us this is a crisis you've
acknowledged this in public and the
answer was no and the reason is because
they say that they only look at
mechanism of action studies sort of
academic science studies on how things
work but the FDA to approve a drug you
need to prove safety and you need to
prove efficacy but you don't have to
have the faintest idea how the drug
works and in fact a lot of the drugs
that are approved we don't really know
how they work but the important thing is
can we reduce suffering can we give them
to people and if it seems to help we
don't need to know the mechanism of
action so at nationals and mental health
though says no we only support these
scientific studies so we've tried the VA
the Department of Defense the National
some mental health a lot of the major
foundations the Wellcome Trust is the
largest foundation in England
started by burrows welcome stock by
pharmaceutical stock they're focused on
neuroscience and psychology and they
said go away it's a reputational risk I
said it's a reputation opportunity yep
well but well let me let me speak to
that because this has been a question a
lot of people have had for me I've been
very public obviously in the New York
Times pieces in Fortune magazine on the
podcast I've spoken very transparently
about mice my support of scientific
research related to these compounds and
I will say that particularly given the
populations we're talking about
victims of sexual abuse disabled
veterans people suffering from PTSD
treatment resistant depression in say
the Hopkins studies I have been
absolutely astonished at the zero amount
of blowback that I have experienced it
has been purely 100 percent reputational
upside and that's not why I did it but I
heard admires and prepared myself to
deal with a bunch of and it
just hasn't come it's been it's been
nothing but it's been nothing but
support and in fact people have reached
out to me who I never thought in a
million years would ever reach out to me
to confide in their own struggles and
also ask how they can help so it's it is
from my perspective as you said not a
reputational risk at all I know that's
strange for me to say and I usually
wouldn't paint such a binary picture but
I really do feel right now it is much
more reputational upside than then
downside so let's do this Rick we've
covered a lot of ground I want to
provide a quick recap to help people
suffice to say there is the capstone
fund this is a 30 million dollar fund to
get MDMA to the finish line I believe in
this I'm committing a million dollars
there is a ten million dollar challenge
grant that can be activated if another
10 million more is raised in the next 90
days I'm going to hold very strong to
that deadline this is all
and you can contribute and learn more if
you're contemplating at least $100,000
over multiple years again tax deductible
by emailing capstone at maps org to
learn more and or going to Mavs org /how
can certainly contribute less and every
dollar does count at maps org but let's
let's I think we should close up soon
because that's that's the message that's
the call to action okay that was that I
think that's that's what we want to
leave fresh in people's minds we'll link
to everything we've discussed all the
names we mentioned Leo Saif Sasha Shogun
all of the books all of the resources
all the compounds they'll all be in the
show notes at teamed up log forward
slash podcast including links to all of
the maps URLs that we mentioned and also
a PSF see the funding collaborative PSF
c dot co but rick what else would you
like to say is there anything else you'd
like to close with before we before we
wrap up well first I'd like to thank you
and Joe green and Graham Boyd at PS FC
for this incredible 10 million dollar
challenge grant and I think what I'd
like to say though is is that while
we're talking a lot about MDMA for PTSD
I think what we're saying is that we're
gonna be unlocking psychedelic
psychotherapy for so many different
things and that there's so many uses of
it and that we are also trying to market
it in a way where we really maximize
public benefit and not profit so I think
we're gonna do two things open the field
to psychedelic psychotherapy and then
also try to demonstrate a new approach
for public health and for pharma and
just to the extent that people can help
us get there we really are doing this
out of love out of passion out of hope
that this is what we can contribute and
that humanity is in a crisis and we've
got to be able to work through our fears
to work together and I think that
I'm very optimistic in that sense I
think we have the tools but we need to
really bring them forward and now is the
time this 10 million dollar challenge
grant is going to be an absolutely
critical component to our ability well
record it's always fun to spend time
with you you're inspiring it you are a
workhorse i I've seen you more than once
running to catch your plane before they
shut the gate with a laptop in one hand
like a waiter running through a
restaurant typing out email here you're
extremely hardworking and this is a
special this is a special moment it's
it's a special opportunity it is time
dependent and I'm also honored and
thrilled to be part of it to be able to
spend time with people like those names
I mentioned who are contributing capital
because they've looked at it and
believed in the the potential
significance which i think is is
enormous and it's a great group of
people to be to be involved with it's
just it's been it's been a real blessing
in my life these are fascinating
thinkers fascinating people and so if if
this is of interest at all if you want
to just explore it please go to maps
dorg forward slash capstone to learn
more and if you've decided that you've
collected some marbles and you don't
want to just sit on your hands waiting
and that this represents a potentially
interesting opportunity please email
capstone at maps org and set up a
meeting to to chat more with with the
team about it but certainly I've only
placed three big bets in this entire
space and this is the third I was only
planning on making two because I wanted
to to tip over some dominoes with the
last two and I I just think with all the
feedback I've had from specialists and
doctors and researchers who assess this
who initially were very very skeptical
we don't have to spend time on it now
but they are now converts and I am very
excited for what's to come
so again to recap it's a ten million
dollar challenge grant that has to be
met within the next 90 days to be
activated map site org forward slash
capstone capstone at maps org if you
have $100,000 or more that you could
potentially put to work to be part of
this if you can contribute anything less
a dollar ten dollars a month whatever it
is everything counts and you can go to
maps or --g which can show you exactly
brick thank you so much for taking the
time I know you're tireless and it
impresses the hell out of me but but
it's but it's still meaningful for you
to to carve out some time to do this so
I I want to thank you for having the
conversation
oh my my pleasure Tim and you know I
think we will be able together to bring
these healing technologies to the world
absolutely and I will leave it there for
now for everybody who has tuned in thank
you for listening and until next time
take care be safe and consider checking
out Maps dot org forward slash caps down
thanks for listening
hey guys this is Tim again just a few
more things before you take off number
one this is five bullet Friday do you
want to get a short email from me would
you enjoy getting a short email from me
every Friday and that provides a little
morsel of fun before the weekend and
five bullet Friday is a very short email
where I share the coolest things I've
found or that I've been pondering over
the week that could include favorite new
albums that I've discovered it could
include gizmos and gadgets and all sorts
of weird that I've somehow dug up
in the the world of the esoteric as I do
it could include favorite articles that
I have read and that I've shared with my
close friends for instance and it's very
short it's just a little tiny bite of
goodness before you head off for the
weekend so if you want to receive that
check it out just go to 4-hour workweek
dot-com
that's 4-hour workweek com all spelled
out and just drop in your email and
you'll get the very next one and if you
sign up I hope you enjoy it
this episode is brought to you by
LinkedIn jobs now more than ever
businesses are grappling with incredibly
challenging times a lot of things in
life and business are changing and we're
all adapting to new priorities while it
does take time to adjust linkedin
believes that it's also possible to find
and create opportunities in times of
turbulence and times of change whether
you're looking to hire now for a
critical role or thinking about needs
that you might have in the future
LinkedIn jobs can help LinkedIn is an
active community with more than 675
million members worldwide LinkedIn
screens candidates for the hard and soft
skills were looking for while putting
your job in front of candidates looking
for job opportunities that match exactly
you have to offer with LinkedIn you can
hire the right person quickly when you
need them and if you need to hire for
health care or essential services you
can post your jobs for free right now
when it's time to find and hire that
right person
LinkedIn is here to help just visit
linkedin.com slash tim again that's
LinkedIn comm slash Tim to post a job
now terms and conditions apply this
podcast episode is brought to you by
helix sleep sleep is super important to
me in the last few years I've come to
conclude it is the end-all be-all
that all good things good mood good
performance good everything seemed to
stem from good sleep so I've tried a lot
to optimize it I've tried pills and
potions all sorts of different
mattresses you name it and for the last
few years I've been sleeping on a helix
midnight luxe mattress I also have one
in the guest bedroom and feedback from
friends has always been fantastic it's
something that they comment on helix
sleep has a quiz takes about two minutes
to complete that matches your body type
and sleep preferences to the perfect
mattress for you with helix there's a
specific mattress for each and every
body that is your body also your taste
so let's say you sleep on your side and
like a super soft bed no problem or if
you're a back sleeper who likes a
mattress that's as firm as a rock
they've got a mattress for you too helix
was selected as the number one best
overall mattress pick of 2020 by GQ
magazine wired Apartment Therapy and
many others just go to helix sleep comm
slash Tim take their two minutes sleep
quiz and they'll match you to a
customized mattress that will give you
the best sleep of your life they have a
10 year warranty
you get to try it out for 100 nights
risk-free I'll even pick it up from you
if you don't love it and now my dear
listeners helix is offering up to $200
off of all mattress orders and two free
pillows at helix sleep comm / Tim these
are not cheap pillows either so getting
two for free is an upgraded deal so
that's up to $200 off
two free pillows at helix sleep calm
slash Tim that's helix HDL is
slash Tim for up to two hundred dollars
off so check it out one more time helix
h e li x sleep calm slash tim
you
[Applause]